clean code clean code is code that's
readable reusable and refactor able and
I'm going to be talking about how to
write clean code in JavaScript
specifically this is about functions
this is part one of my clean code
functions the first thing to consider
when writing functions is the function
arguments ideally there should be two or
fewer arguments so instead of having
this function with one two three four
arguments we're going to pull the
arguments into in objects we're gonna
put and then we're just gonna call the
menu with just the one argument the next
thing is that function should do only
one thing you can see in this function
is function email clients it's sending
the clients in and for each client it's
setting the client record equals
database that lookup client and then if
client record is active it's going to
email client so it's actually doing two
things it's checking if the client is
active and then it's emailing the client
so a better way would be to change this
into two functions so now we have the
function email client and it's going to
only email the client it's going to
filter it by its client active and
that's going to call this other function
its client active which is going to look
up the client and it's going to return
if it's active so now instead of doing
two things
each there's two functions that use do
one thing next up is that function name
should say what they do so look at this
function function add to date we're
passing in a date and we're gonna pass
in a month so why are we passing in a
month what what exactly are we adding if
you if you call this a date date one
it's not exactly clear what's happening
so we're going to change this to add
month to date and then we're gonna put
the month first
but that date second and so we're gonna
add the first month to the date and now
it's more obvious that we're adding the
month to date instead just add today add
month to date so it's more clear what
the function is doing the next thing is
that function should only be one level
of abstraction this kind of goes along
with functions should only do one thing
so let me put in a function here and
when you do split up functions that
leads to reusable and easier testing so
let's look at this function we've got
parse better jcf alternative and now
this is a pretty long function code
we're passing the code we have the read
reg X's we have statements equals code
splits splitting at the space and we
have tokens empty array then for each
reg X we're going to call this function
for each of the statements maybe the
Const ast empty array tokens for each
token ask that part s dot for each node
and we're gonna actually just try to
break this up into a few different
things we're gonna try to separate
listen to a few step 3 different things
we're gonna separate this token section
from from the ast section and let me
just paste that in there and then we can
talk about it ok so here's here's the
original and here's where it's broken up
a little more we're so we're gonna end
with the parts better JSA alternatives
now that's the the same as what the
original function was called but now
instead of doing all these things in one
function we're pushing out some of the
things so kant's tokens equals tokenized
code Const ast equals lexer tokens and
then ast that for each node and I'm
gonna party to one so first we're just
going to get the tokens tokens tokenize
so if you go up and tokenize so we're
gonna we're gonna take this this is
basically just the first step of some of
the things up there and then we're going
to
take the do the get the AMU turn the ast
down here so we're just breaking that up
a little bit to make him more readable
and also so it's only one little ater of
abstraction for each function so let's
go this next one remove duplicate code
duplicate code is bad because there's
that means there's more than one place
to change something if you need to
change some logic so if you only have
put in one spot then you only have to
change in one spot something needs to be
changed so here's an example of two
functions functions show developer list
developers developer for each developer
console expected salary equals developer
calculate expected salary cons
experience equals developer experience
cons github blank equals developer deck
github link if you look down here
functions show management list managers
managers debt for each manager cons
expected salary equals manager data
calculate expected salary cons
experience equals managed to get
experience before we go so the only
thing different between these two
functions is once called developer one
was called manager and the developer has
a github link and the manager has a
portfolio and then the data appeared
equals it has to get home link to my
data down here it's a portfolio but the
expected salary and experience are the
same they expected salary and experience
are the same so it's almost exactly the
same this is a perfect example of
something that you should be able to
break down so you don't have the
duplicate duplicate code so what we're
gonna do is we're going to completely
remove this second function I want to
update this first one so it's it can
apply to both developers and managers so
we're going to change this just show
list and step passing a developer we're
gonna pass in an employee
and change this all at one time I just
did command D after changing my settings
so it used sublime text key mappings now
the github link is things that's gonna
be different so a github link is still
considered kind of portfolio for
developers so we're going to call that
portfolio but here's where we're gonna
make it a little different um we're
gonna get can do the employed at github
blank but then down here if we find out
it's a manager then we're going to get
MBA projects and since we're gonna be
possibly changing this we're gonna
instead of constant gonna put left here
because let allows you to change and
counts does not and if there is no and
github link up here this is just going
to be either null so then you can
actually get the MBA projects down here
now for the cons data we're just going
to change this to portfolio and now
we've just combined those two functions
into one function last up is don't use
flags as function parameters flags tell
your user that the function does more
than one thing functions should just do
one thing so you can split your
functions if they're following different
code paths based on a boolean for
example if you have this function create
file we have the name and temp if temp
function FX type create and even create
this else at the subtree name so it's
based on what this boolean is or what
this flag is instead doing like this we
can tick off this tip here and just if
we need to create the file we can do
that and we're not gonna have an else
we're just gonna have another function
so
so if you need to create the temp file
then you just call a different function
there instead of just one function that
you use a boolean or a flat to figure
out what you're going to do just create
two functions and you just call
different function depending on what you
want to do well that's it for part 1 of
functions if you check the description
you can see a link to what inspired this
video don't forget to subscribe and
remember use your code for good